[Musique]
la loi sur le vin est approuvée
[des rires]
en désarroi en appréciant eliot engel par
la différence d'inclusion totale dans
sauce en forme de konami en hindi minimal
Dans Lantern 16 Cast Session That
prétend soi-disant avoir la vie à l'intérieur
version de danse
[Musique]
et
dans
ce sentiment que la monnaie a un avenir
on va croire que
avec cette mise en œuvre que le gouvernement
il va être utilisé dans le pays
sa valeur va monter et puis ça va
générer des profits plus élevés
[Musique]
Je n'aime pas ça pour un moment
je l'accepte
J'aime que quelqu'un me dise combien
Il a vendu jusqu'à la file d'attente je dis
regarder le relâchement du portefeuille comme
quelqu'un me dit et je vois mon pisto
combien vendu mais c'est une arnaque
Ce qui arrive est un vol, pas moi, ce n'est pas moi
comme
[Musique]
l'irrégularité avec laquelle il est traité
cette pièce porte également un
situation très compliquée alors
nous et nous exigeons la
l'abrogation de cette loi n'est pas nécessaire
avoir précisément des téléphones
intelligent que les gens ont
compréhension de la technologie et que
cela générera que les gens peuvent
frauder et générer de graves dommages
fait une économie
[Musique]